une course contre la montre en ce moment
la mère de gustavo et à vieira subi des
traitements de chimiothérapie
en attendant une greffe de cellules
souches pour combattre un lymphome
agressif pour trouver le donne en avant
que les chimie aux banques finissent par
jeter un peu plus calme et finisse par
lâcher
mère de trois enfants jessica soto est
arrivé du chili adolescente elle a 50
ans et travaille depuis des années
auprès des itinérants à montréal
en ce moment on est par son bureau
maintenant qu'est ce qu'a fait dans la
vie c'est à l'aide les gens qui ont des
maladies mentales qui sont dans la rue
j'aimerais tellement tellement seul
combien redonne le cadeau qu'a fait au
quotidien à des gens le qu'on puisse
vraiment lui trouver le m1 d'honneur
pour qu'elle puisse continuer sa vie
depuis le diagnostic en juin le temps
s'est arrêté pour ses collègues aussi
toute la famille a été testé ils sont
pas compatibles donc l'écouter on fait
un appel à tous aux latinos aux latino
américain american du sis au québec par
la suite on va aller plus loin en
amérique latine les principaux registre
dont ceux du canada sont dans des pays
où la population de prédominance est de
race blanche et donc caucasienne l'appel
vise à diversifier l'origine des
donneurs du registre d'héma québec
lorsqu'on réalise une grève de ses deux
chouchous
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on va
rechercher un donneur que le même bagage
génétique que le receveur
cela rappelle le cas de mike douanes en
la jeune femme d'origine vietnamienne
est en rémission de son cancer et la
population asiatique est bien représenté
dans leur registre d'héma québec héma
québec a déjà reçu des centaines
d'appels aujourd'hui de gens qui veulent
obtenir la trousse en vue de faire le
premier test génétique
l'appel a commencé à se propager sur les
réseaux sociaux
de l'hôpital en compagnie de son autre
fils jessica s'auto apprend la
mobilisation qui vient de naître autour
d'elle ici anne louise despatie radio
canada montréal